today on campaign check we're taking a
look at education one of the key
battlegrounds of any election campaign
and this morning the Lib Dem leader Joe
Swinton addressed inequality in the
classroom claiming that the achievement
gap between richer and poorer children
can best be closed in the early years
but under the Conservatives is widening
so is she right that the most
disadvantaged pupils are lagging behind
because of the Tories this chart shows
how many months pupils to get free
school meals are behind their peers and
you can see that by GCSEs poorer pupils
are just over 18 months behind now the
gap has been narrowing which is why this
line is going down and it's ascending in
primary schools too but progress is
slowing and last year the GCSE gap
actually got wider and in early years
which is for children up to five years
old that's what the Lib Dems have been
talking about it's the same story the
gap has been falling a little but lately
it's widened so Joe Swinton is correct
although we should say only just because
the gap that she refers to was
inequality by the end of reception year
it's only widened by the equivalent of
three days and the think-tank that makes
this data says in the early years there
was no substantial change to the gap now
of course this technical discussion
risks missing the point which is that
the gap starts early in life gets larger
and shows no sign of closing so what are
the main pipes going to do about it well
they've all pledged extra money for
schools labour and the Greens more
substantially although the Lib Dems have
also pledged a significant sum to revive
35 hours of free childcare but given the
scale of the gap even the largest sums
are unlikely to make a difference the
impartial Education Policy Institute
suggests that at the current rate of
progress it would take more than 500
years to close the GCC attainment gap
that would take us up to the Year 2581
and when they assess the manifesto the
manifestos they found that the parties
pledges were unlikely to deliver so Joe
Swinson is right to say the attainment
gap is widening
that the earliest is the most effective
place to fix it but if the Lib Dems are
any party just they can close the gap
with their funding of puzzles that claim
will need a lot of scrutiny